هذه بحسب الجيش الامريكي طائره تجسس كانت
تطير في الاجواء الدوليه فوق المياه
الدوليه للبحر الاسود ولكن هاتان
الطائرتان الروسيتان من طراز
27 اس
حاولتا اعتراض هذه الطائره
واسقطتها اولا
مواد نفطيه على هذه الطائره المسيره قبل
ان تقوم احدى هاتين الطائرتين الروسيتين
بصدم مروحه الطائره المسيره الامريكيه مما
ادى عمليا الى اسقاطها والمسؤولون
الامريكيون يقولون ان الطائره الروسيه
ايضا تحطمت في المياه
الدوليه للبحر الاسود هناك اصرار امريكي
على ان هذه الاجواء دوليه وهذه المياه
دوليه ويحق الجيش الامريكي ان يقوم
بالممارسات الاعتياديه كان تحليقا في
المنطقه او ابحارا في المياه الاقليميه
الدوليه للبحر الاسود ولكن هناك ايضا
الكثير اقرار بان هناك الكثير من التوتر
مع الجانب الروسي بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهذه هي اول مره التي يحصل فيها هذا النوع
من الصدام بين طائرتين عسكريتين
روسيه
وامريكيه بطبيعه الحال الرئيس جو بايدن
اطلع على هذا الحادث ولكن البيت الابيض
حاول
التخفيف من حده المشكله بالقول ان هذه
الممارسات غير اعتياديه غير المهنيه ليست
غير اعتياديه من الجانب الروسي وهناك
انتقادات كثيره طبعا للجانب الروسي في هذا